notre question un autre sujet brûlant
dans l'actualité aujourd'hui ce sont
notamment ces images construites et ses
angles aux sectes ans ces anglo saxons
par dont certains sont des touristes ce
sont des images des débordements et des
tirs de gaz lacrymogènes à paris le
bilan c'est à montpellier une femme
fauchée par un supporters une famille
fauché par un supporter bilan une mère
de famille de 42 ans tué un enfant
polytraumatisé 73 garde à vue 20
policiers blessés des commerces pillés à
paris des incidents à tourcoing a ou b
et dans d'autres villes
c'est l'essentiel du bilan des
débordements hier soir à l'issue de ce
qui a été il faut le reconnaître une
véritable performance celle réalisée par
les fennecs algériens victorieux de la
côte d'ivoire en quarts de finale de la
coupe d'afrique des nations il n'en
reste pas mois que les incidents sont
inacceptables c'est en tout cas en ces
termes que les a qualifié le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner je veux
de la façon la plus claire condamné ces
comportements qui ne sont pas
acceptables
ceux qui se sont livrés à cela mais
prise au fond à la fois les valeurs du
sport les valeurs du football mais aussi
le pays dont ils ont célébré la victoire
dans ce match parce que se comporter
ainsi c'est aussi faire insulte à ce
pays et je le regrette profondément
il y aura des sanctions et des moyens
renforcés pour que ces comportements
soient systématiquement neutraliser et
que nous puissions poursuivre les
auteurs étienne girard est ce que la
réaction est à la hauteur
en tout cas la préfecture a été
manifestement prise au dépourvu et on
est dans un
un échec policiers qu'il faut noter
puisque on a quand même 43 ans
interpellations sur une situation à
nation à paris oui parce que oui il ya
74 oui en relation au niveau national
dont 73 garde à vue oui j'étais sur
paris ça et la situation était
sous-estimé alors que on savait très
bien qu'il y avait un match de l'algérie
et donc qu'il y allait y avoir
possiblement des manifestations dans les
rues ensuite là-dessus ah oui il ya un
échec qu'il faut qu'il faut noter du
gouvernement c'est la réponse la réponse
de fermeté on est dans la langue de bois
ou là ou en tout cas les figures
imposées de ce genre de communication
n'ya rien tellement intéressant du
notable dessus on veut on précise peut
être que didier lallement a été le
préfet de paris avait été nommé à paris
pour justement mettre en oeuvre la
fermeté qu'on l'avait vu voir mettre en
oeuvre à bordeaux voilà dans une équipe
inévitablement il y aura dix ont une
impression de deux poids deux mesures
c'est à dire on est ferme avec les gilet
jaune et on est plutôt laxiste avec les
supporters algériens le problème
regrette nicole notamment oui c'est le
cas c'est contre cette observation et
c'est ce moment mais derrière ne
manquera pas de tourner à la fois sur
les réseaux et même dans les
commentaires politiques
le problème c'est que je suis d'accord
avec vous il ya un défaut d'anticipation
on sait que les matchs de l'algérie sont
des matches qui donc mieux de manière
régulière à des manifestations qui sont
parfois pour le moins intempestives et
là le problème c'est qu'elles ne sont
pas on en s'adressant non seulement
intempestives et mais il faut qu'à
montpellier il ya eu une
il ya eu un mort donc ce défaut
d'anticipation manifestement je dire on
le fera en france on en fera porter la
responsabilité au préfet de police et au
et au gouvernement
il ya autre chose quand même parce que
l'algérie c'est un sujet sensible ça
reste un sujet très sensible dans
l'imaginaire politique français et
quelque part je vois déjà les
commentaires de ceux qui aujourd'hui
considèrent que finalement il n'y a pas
de société multiculturelle heureuse
parce que c'est ça inévitablement qui va
d'une certaine façon être aussi véhiculé
par c'est par ces images donc la
réaction d'ailleurs de du ministre de
l'intérieur est intéressante parce que
c'est une réaction qui vise finalement à
préserver l'image de marque de l'algérie
quand on entend on dire finalement ces
manifestations font insulte à l'algérie
donc on voit que le ministre de
l'intérieur lui-même est dans une
position qui vise d'une certaine manière
a essayé disons de 2,2 de défendre cette
idée que finalement je veux dire la
relation avec l'algérie est une relation
absolument essentiel et donc qu'il faut
la protéger
je suis pas sûr qu'en l'occurrence ça
soit une parole qui soit là aussi
totalement audible pour les gens qui
voient ces images
oui c'est un effet je crois qu'on a on a
dit beaucoup de choses mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas un sujet qui est sûre ça
vient de dire ce que vient dire ah bah
oui c'est pas tout à fait inattendue les
matchs algériens ou le comportement des
supporteurs algériens vous le souvenir
moment quand il allait siffler la
marseillaise une fois dans le stade de
france et que le président était parti
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut enlever
prévoir et en effet on pourra
s'interroger on s'interroge sur le deux
poids deux mesures sur en effet une
répression très très très forte
vis-à-vis des huiles et jaune est là en
effet une compréhension et on va dire ça
comme ça
moi ce qui me frappe mais là je vais
peut-être faire un peu du castanet rossi
ce qui me frappe c'est dans cette
matière notamment le comportement des
algériens en algérie en egypte et
remarquable vous savez qu'ils laissent
les stades impeccable il nettoie tout de
même que leur révolution et
remarquablement non violente et je
trouve que ruud je retravaille un
contraste entre les algériens de france
où les franco algériens parce que neuf
dixième d'entre eux sont doubles
nationaux et
les algériens d'algérie qui interroge
sur le phénomène d'acculturation part et
d'autre de la méditerranée et sur le
fait que l'algérie
il ya une vraie une vraie différence
entre ces deux communautés et c'est
c'est peut-être qu'ils en rajoutent dans
la loyauté vis-à-vis de l'algérie mais
il ne se comporte pas comme leurs frères
outre méditerranée
ceux qui y ont il ya 2 il ya deux
dossiers il ya le cas mineur de une
série de gens peu recommandables qui
sont des supporters de foot comme on
peut voir parfois les supporters de
marseille et du psg s'écharper au coeur
de paris au coeur de marseille donc on
notera d'ailleurs spécialement
d'incidents
de ce point de vue là c'est assez
inqualifiable moi je je ne
jetterai pas l'opprobre sur les forces
policières qu'ont vécu quand même 28
mois extrêmement extrêmement difficile
il ya une série d'abrutis qui descendent
dans la rue c'est pas toujours la faute
des policiers les gens peuvent se tenir
correctement
après c'est vrai qu'on attend sans doute
une réaction assez ferme de la part d'un
pouvoir algérien en ce moment qui est un
petit peu contrarié qui pourrait
dénoncer ce genre d'attitude dès lors
qu'on voit le drapeau algérien qui est
brandi dans les rues de paris ça serait
intéressant d'observer ça et après de la
part du ministre de l'intérieur et bien
il aura pu assez rapidement expliqué que
si les gens font condamner et bien
double nationaux ils pourraient être
immédiatement reconduit à la frontière
parce qu'on ne souhaite pas que les gens
comme ça qui ont plus de surcroît ont
fait ont provoqué la mort d'une petite
fille reste sur sur le territoire doit
être ça aurait pu ces dames en plus
élargi après par rapport à la relation
avec l'algérie
elle est essentielle l'algérie a un rôle
très important dans le confinement de
certains islamistes aux frontières de la
tunisie donc qu'on souhaite l'aménager
c'est normal maintenant savoir
grand-chose avec l'attitude de
supporters qui ont des attitudes
scandaleuse voilà donc un la police les
soient un peu tranquilles et 2 sans
doute que assez fréquemment
il faudrait que sur ces sujets là
monsieur castaner soit un peu plus
autoritaire qu'il retrouve les échos
qu'il a eu en tout cas le ton qu'il a eu
parfois lors de grandes manifestations
du gilet jaune
eric ciotti marine le pen réclame des
mesures énergiques dimanche pour les
demi-finales nigeria algérie
rassemblement national on demande même
l'interdiction de l'accès aux champs
elysées où l'interdiction du drapeau
algérien
c'est grotesque on va punir n'importe
quel supporters algériens parce qu'il ya
quelques dizaine d'imbéciles qui font
des exactions et qui se trouve être par
ailleurs ou se revendiquer de l'équipe
nationale algérienne vous rendez compte
de ce qui pourrait se passer
on a un groupe de supporters algériens
tout à fait pacifistes et on va les
arrêter et on va les interpellé juste
parce qu'ils ont un drapeau nom et sur
le sur l'interdiction des champs elysées
alors c'est délicat
il me semble que ça montrerait à une
fébrilité des forces de l'ordre donc
qu'ils reconnaîtraient qu'ils sont
incapables de gérer la situation et donc
incapable d'ouvrir à une avenue aussi
est usité que les champs elysées sans
que la solution la plus naturelle qui
est la solution habituelle dans ce genre
de circonstance et un renforcement du 18
une adaptation du dispositif policier
moi je fais corps avec avec etienne
quand les supporters de l'om et du psg
soit incapable de se tenir et bien on
interdit aux supporters d'une des deux
équipes de décembre dans une trappe le
symbole n'est pas leur liberté de se
déplacer et seule la police est avec une
décision de justice peut faire ça à
partir du moment où les gens ne peut se
retenir salissent effectivement le
drapeau d'un pays parce que je suis
persuadé que les algériens qui voient ça
soit absolument furieux que certains qui
se revendiquent de leurs compatriotes
puissent salir ce drapeau il faut leur
interdire leur présence sur les
champs-elysées comme on interdit aux
supporters abrutis de se rendre à paris
si jamais les marseillais savent pas se
tenir et lycée de versailles est comme
il est je crois qu'il faut être assez
ferme et à la fois les algériens parce
que certains sont scandalisés de voir ça
et les français qui pourra être tenté
d'écouter peut-être des avis un peu trop
compliqué vous voyez de qui je parle et
où tout le monde sera content donc il
faut être assez ferme
je donne la parole à arnaud benedetti
mais avant nous
un autre petit show nous dit peu importe
la réaction du gouvernement le vrai
problème c'est la dérive communautariste
du pays
s'il se dit que pour lui la fermeté
c'est simplement pour les ouvriers arcus
deals sont a puni et ça recommencera
dimanche
il ya camille 74 interpellations
nick nous dit puisque c'est systématique
avec eu peur pourquoi ne pas avoir
interdit les champs elysées et arcus
estime que le discours d'alger de macron
sur les crimes contre l'humanité
autorise toutes les dérives
écoutez ce qu'on peut imaginer que de
toute façon pour le prochain match qui
allégeront dandinant j manche c'est la
préfecture de police prendra des mesures
certainement beaucoup plus anticiper
beaucoup plus dense pour essayer
d'éviter ce type de de débordements mais
encore une fois moi je pense que ces
images apporte de l'eau au moulin à ceux
qui combattent et qui considèrent que la
société finalement multiculturelle en
france constitue un échec
la relation avec l'algérie est une
relation extrêmement complexe parce
qu'en plus la france à 10 ont
intériorisé une forme de complexe
coloniale par rapport à son passé et de
culpabilité de culpabilité alors à tort
ou à raison en tout cas c'est une
réalité en même temps on sent très bien
qu' il y a la volonté comme l'a dit
jacky isabello de la part des
gouvernants français de ne pas en
rajouter parce que l'algérie constitue
quand même un tampon un disons 1
un moyen d'éviter quelque part une
propagation une propagation islamistes
dans cette zone donc on est
vraisemblablement à la fois pris entre
notre complexe de culpabilité
la réelle politique et puis aussi une
grande partie de l'opinion publique
française qui manifestement condamnera
ce type d'image qui va se demander si
algérie doit gagner ou perdre car dans
les deux cas il y aura de la violence et
arcus encore le drapeau algérien sur les
champs-elysées le jour de la fête
nationale serait une provocation
le drapeau le drapeau c'est quand même
un symbole de c2c directe de ces joies
sportives c'est qu'on ne sait pas qui me
gêne les champs-elysées en revanche vois
pas pourquoi les interdirait part avec
les risques de casse et de pillage
puisqu'il ya eu des pillages aussi alors
qu'on a interdit depuis six mois au
gilet jaune et que justement on
considère que c'est une preuve de
fermeté là je crois que de l'ordre
public
la préfecture doit prendre des mesures
effectives et notamment dans une période
touristique très importante notamment
parce que les riverains des
champs-elysées commence à en avoir un
petit peu marre je crois que ça ne
poserait aucun problème de baliser et de
dire là c'est pas possible comme on le
fait c'est tout simplement de l'ordre
public les champs elysées ne sont pas
ouverts nécessairement toutes les
manifestations essayez d'ailleurs
maintes de manifester à proximité du
palais l'elysée vous verrez que je peux
vous garantir que une certainement il y
avait un dispositif
il faudrait voir en tout cas bien mais
certainement dispositif plus forts près
du palais hier pensez vous que les
pouvoirs publics et le gouvernement
aurait dû avoir une réaction plus ferme
après des débordements survenus hier
soir lors de la qualification de
l'algérie pour la demi finale de la can
il ya c'est la question qu'on vous pose
sur twitter hashtag finir live
#primaires but est pour l'instant vous
êtes une large une écrasante majorité à
répondre oui
86 % exactement
on y reviendra et on suit va d'ailleurs
la demi finale de cette can dimanche
sera à suivre et il est suite à en
direct sur lefigaro.fr et sur figaro
live